do you know that scientists have created  many brains also known as organoids in  lab and this work is pioneered by dr  madeleine lancaster at the mrc labs  cambridge  they have generated organoids which  strikingly resembles the human embryonic  brain upon molecular examination  scientists found that the organization  of neurons and the stem cells are  strikingly similar in order to grow  these organoids in lab they start with  stem cell colony from where they  generate aggregates in 96 well plates  eventually they transfer these  aggregates into mini bioreactors with  the help of proper media and growth  conditions these  organoids eventually develop and show  features of a mini brain  labrun mini brains  transforms the way we think about  biomedical research and clinical  diagnosis  after this path breaking research  scientists throughout the world started  generating mini organs in their  laboratory